[Musique]
depuis que je suis dans cette fonction
je me dis on est le chaînon manquant de
l'information sur l'europe de
l'intégration européenne on est proche
de nos élus locaux en et chaque semaine
dans nos circonscriptions
on est devant nos électeurs donc nous
devons porter ces questions on a des
défis et comment trouvons-nous des
solutions aujourd'hui pour répondre à
ces défis et je crois que c'est en
premier le ça qui intéresse les gens ils
savent bien que les problèmes
climatiques s'arrête pas à nos
frontières plus aucun état membre a un
poids tout seul suffisant pour y
répondre et ça c'est des choses que nous
devons absolument porter et on ne le
fait pas suffisamment donc nous devons
aussi gagner en visibilité sur les
questions comme ça en tant que
parlements nationaux
machenaud parlement joe jack white ou
gaza
1,5 euro par les matchs où
nous
travaillons depuis à peu près un an à la
création du groupe de travail pour
donner une dimension beaucoup plus
visible de cet organisme qui est peu
connue finalement qui travaille beaucoup
mais assez dans l'ombre et avec une
méthode de travail qui aujourd'hui ne
satisfait pas finalement tous les
parlements donc dans les discussions
avec nos collègues parlementaires et
pour avoir une approche partagée avec
eux nous avons eu cette idée de créer
deux groupes de travail pour dire on va
plus loin que ces séances de rencontres
au général qu'on a pour avoir une
réflexion de fond beaucoup plus
importante qui pourrait peser dans
l'avenir sur les décisions ou de la
commission ou du parlement européen en
tout cas c'est avec eux qu'on veut
travailler on veut créer un espace
aurait elle été on se connaît pas et
donc c'est comme ces groupes de travail
quelque part je vais être un peu
familier c'est comme une partir avec des
amis en vacances vous revenez vous êtes
encore amis vous avez fait un grand pas
en avant et pour se connaître vos
travailler ensemble
[Musique]